hello everyone
hello hi
hello
so I hope everybody's here for the right
talk this is pandas at a Crossroads the
past present and future uh my name is
Jeffrey back
today first time to give you the key
important legalese slide that uh two
Sigma we don't offer investment advice
at this talk
okay this talk is not this is purely
about pandas
um so I'll tell you a little bit about
myself I'm a former Quant
um
not loud enough sorry okay let me put
the mic over here great
better yeah okay
I'm a former Quant I've been a core
committed to pandas for the last 10
years I've been managing Panda since
about 2013.
I've been at Tucson for about five years
I'm a manager director at tusigwa and
I'm working on holistic approaches to
modeling okay some of which will will
show you a very brief Glimpse today
so two Sigma is passionate about open
source we're committed to sustaining the
digital infrastructure for the public
good and that manifests in both building
our own projects and building on the
work of others for example we've created
a couple of projects that we've
subsequently open sourced for example
Beaker X which is a plug-in it's a
polyglot plug-in that we have uh you
know contributed to Jupiter actually
uh some other projects we have are cook
which is a fair process scheduler uh
recently we open sourced a fast freeze
which is an interesting way of freezing
the Linux kernel and then actually
saving it to disk and reopening it
pretty interesting we've contributed to
many projects as well uh you know just
code wise like spark Apache spark for
example and we of course fund a number
of projects Jupiter
um you can actually catch a talk by
Diego later today in this room about
some of that uh action that we have
there we've we're funding uh various
aspects of pandas of course parts of
Arrow and on the whole ecosystem wide we
we have funded Debian in 2022 and I'm
focused the last five years and the
python software Foundation also for the
last five years
so in this talk I want to cover a few
things first I'll talk a little bit
about myself and how I came to be the
principal maintainer of what is arguably
the most critical and used data science
library in the world
I'll talk about the responsibilities and
challenges that come along with
maintaining pandas I'll give some
context of the data science tools
available and how pandas is being pushed
to the Limit
and I'll show why pandas is at a
Crossroads
there are three options that we see for
moving forward
finally I'll leave you with more
questions than answers
so why pandas
or let's first talk about what is pandas
pandas is a python package that provides
fast flexible and expressive data
structures designed to make working with
relational or labeled data both easy and
intuitive primarily this is the data
frame abstraction so a data frame is a
two-dimensional labeled data structure
with Columns of potentially different
types you can think of it as like a
spreadsheet or SQL table pandas adds an
optional index for both row and column
labels
so here's just a few things that pandas
does well
automatic and explicit data alignment
objects can be explicitly aligned on a
set of labels or the user can simply
ignore this and let pandas automatically
line the labels for you in computation
a handling of missing data for many data
types and size mutability columns can be
inserted or deleted from the data frames
pandas has powerful flexible Group by
functionality to perform the split apply
combined operation on data sets for both
aggregating and transforming data
pandas has intelligent label based
indexing intuitive and flexible joining
reshaping and pivoting operations
pandas has robust i o tools for reading
and writing data from various formats
for example CSV excels files databases
Json XML and a number of binary formats
for example parquet and hdf5
and pin is actually probably pretty well
known for its time series specific
functionality such as moving window
statistics and date shifting
oh
this is an important thing
put this on
okay
all right is that better
a little better okay great
should I start at the beginning again
just kidding just kidding
um so this is where Panda sits from a
user point of view uh one of the primary
use cases is the user interacting with
data they're both transforming it in
both a pre and post dispatching to other
libraries so you know pandas you'll
transform your features you'll send it
to your favorite machine learning
library and then once you get them back
you'll do some post-processing uh you
know pandas has many inbuilt
functionality but it's augmented by the
huge python ecosystem machine learning
numerical libraries such as scipy and
numpy IO oops I O libraries and
graphical libraries
um pandas is really the Swiss army knife
it's especially useful for any ad hoc
analysis and greatly used in production
so this is a slide that Jake vanderplas
has presented several years ago it's
showing uh really there's a hierarchy
where libraries in the python oops in
the python ecosystem build upon one
another you know everybody of course
Builds on the python you know base
distribution where you have numpy and
then you have cython and so on pandas is
sort of up in the stack a little bit and
then other libraries are in turn
building on a pandas itself
so there's of course been a tremendous
growth in Python itself over the last
like 10 years this is a graph showing
various languages and the metric here is
uh stack Overflow questions as a
percentage okay
uh this is a similar graph but this is
specific to packages in uh you know in
the python ecosystem some of the core
packages here you know the Django for
many years has been doing super awesome
and you can see the recent rise of uh
data science packages in the last five
years uh coincidentally I started
managing pandas in about 2013.
so uh this is a quote I I stumbled upon
on Twitter
um this dovetails oops with the slide
before showing the stack Overflow
metrics you know
stack over the questions you know can
often be bug reports but they can often
be helped by random users and that is
probably one of the you know the
greatest strengths here is the fact that
uh you know you can find any answer you
know on pandas on stack Overflow so
pandas I think is wildly Successful by
this measure
um so here's a little bit of History
pandas uh in 20 uh the 2008 2009 time
frame pandas was started at acre in 2015
we joined num Focus
and we've only received funding in the
2019 time frame uh we've had no
full-time Manors until very recently and
I'll talk about them in a second
this is a graphic uh by done by num
Focus uh three or four years ago this is
sort of showing the cost of building
pandas but this is also on cost
um really what is is the trick here is
is the ongoing maintenance and
enhancement of pandas this is actually
probably a larger cost than you know was
put in originally so
we need to you know find a way to make
pandas sustainable
and so as I mentioned you know starting
in 2019 we began to receive funding from
various
um various places the transaction
initiative uh the University of Southern
California Intel NASA and so on and so
forth
um and at this point we actually have
three full-time maintainers
um one in a video One sponsored by until
and one through a
NASA Grant they are you know managed by
quantite
um so pandas really has transitioned
from a all volunteer to some some paid
maintainers which is which is great and
this really enhances the sustainability
of the ecosystem
I'm personally supported by two Sigma
I'm not actually paid for pandas per se
but I do work explicitly so
um here's some uses of some of these
funds
um
we actually used some funds from the
Chan Zuckerberg initiative to build out
uh string back to raise uh with pyro
this was actually a joint venture with
the Aero project where we actually did a
lot of the work uh in in Arrow itself
and then we was pulled into pandas
uh recently we've added and this was
just released in 1.5 uh non-nanosecond
daytime support this was uh supported by
the University of Southern California
uh I guess geophysicists need this
you know very fine-grained daytime
support
um we have a joint venture uh with uh
this NASA Grant and I say joint venture
because it's across the entire ecosystem
it includes numpy and socket learn
as well as pandas and the idea here is
to build
um uh apis that can work across the
entire ecosystem in a cohesive way for
example in in parallelization support
and we're working through a grant uh
from boto AI to implement various API
improvements
um
we have an additional Grant from czi so
this this is actually a different kind
of Grant this is to enhance the pandas
maintenance maintenance experience so
the idea is to build maintainers you
know
even though we have some paid
maintainers the the backbone really is
the volunteers to pandas and so we want
to continue to enhance their experience
just make it better and this is also
again across the ecosystem including
numpy mapleb and scipy
so you may recognize this fellow this is
uh Wes McKinney he was originally
founder of pandos uh back in 2008 and he
worked on the project for a number of
years
um he gets all the kudos
this is me I get all the complaints
um so for much of the early time on
pandas this is from 2013 to 2017. I
think this is 2017 graph
um I did mostly actual code I committed
you know quite a bit to pandas this is
me today virtually all code review I
mean pandas has grown up it's really a
project it's a very sprawling project
lots and lots of code across you know
many different subsystems
luckily inside two Sigma I do get the
code and so that's kind of fun
um interesting enough uh over time I
think I've gone from
yes to no so you know in the early days
you know as uh you know people who are
at startups uh they would say yes to
everything let's add new features and
and lately it's been all no
so let's talk a little bit about the
pandas API
so appendix is one of the premium data
science libraries uh we need to and do
take care I think probably backwards
compatibility drives a tremendous number
of decisions nowadays we're really
trying to not break the users this is
actually quite hard because oftentimes
we don't even know who the users are we
don't have good Telemetry
um interestingly inside two Sigma I can
simply look up a metric dashboard and
see who's using my function and just
change it I can't do that in open source
and this makes really migrations a lot
more tricky
so pandas are used by nearly every
Fortune 100 company for research and
production workloads
it has 80 million plus monthly downloads
we don't have any good metrics on the
user base but it's likely a large
multiple of this
and pandas is crucial is is critical to
two segments used like in something like
90 of research workflows
this is a quote by James Powell I don't
know if he's actually in this room but
he's at this conference
um
and in effect he's saying pandas is
useful it's very expressive it's good
great for ad hoc analysis and it is
actually performant so in spite of what
you've heard
um you know it does a pretty good job
so let's talk about the API a little bit
so pandas is designed around a fluent
API method Cheney
and as I mentioned one of the driving
principles is really a commitment to to
backwards compatibility
however
it's really I'll call it open source
iterative over time and this is really
one of the glaring weaknesses right now
is the fact that like if our design pan
is today I would do something probably
completely different I would
intentionally design uh things in a
different way but we can't do that we've
we've designed things over time and
so we have to iterate from where we were
to a better place may not be the perfect
place but that's okay
so for example
um you know a lot of the early
influences were R in SQL and I think
we're moving to a world where these
converge even more
um example you know why does pandas not
have a select for example and so we have
the exact same functionality it's just
not coded in that way it's not you can't
write it in that way so I think you know
as uh you know over time I think we're
going to be adding more and more of
these
um we'll call it spellings which allow
us to make newcomers to pandas uh you
know make it an even even easier
transition
so around pandas is a tremendous
ecosystem of libraries which are we'll
call it data frame-like these generally
are distributed data frame libraries uh
not exclusively though so for example
this is dasc It's a task scheduler built
in Python which implements a data from
interface uh Das data frames use pandas
internally in the workers and provides
an API similar to pandas it's adapted to
its distributed and lazy nature
Vex for example is an out-of-core
alternative to pandas uses hdf5 to
create memory maps that avoid loading
data sets to memory some parts of Vex
are implemented C plus
uh moden is a distributed data from
library originally built on Ray but has
a more modular but it has a more modular
way that allows it to use task as a
schedule as well or replace the pen can
also replace the Panda's public API less
equal light one
uh Rapids uh sorry a qdf is a GPU data
frame built on top of Apache arrow and
Rapids provides the API similar to
pandas
uh Pi spark is a data frame library that
uses Spark as a back end Pi spark public
API is based on the original spark API
and not on pandas but spark.pandas is a
thing now
so you can get the same API using spark
and polars is a data frame Library built
in Rust using Apache Arrow under the
hood for data storage there was actually
a talk Yesterday by Juan Luis on polars
check it out
so all these libraries are all about
lazy evaluation
um they are large to a large extent
mimicking the pandas API and you know of
course pandas is an eager evaluated
Library
and I'm going to mention one more
Library here so this is Ibis it's a high
level python API for data analysis
um it has a fluent Panda's like syntax
but not a lot of things are not
necessarily spelled exactly like pandas
some are it takes a lot of inspiration
from SQL and some from r uh it can
express virtually any SQL query
um
and it supports a module back ends for
querying systems
oops
so it can support all these dbms's as
well as Big Data Systems such as a
patchy spark bigquery Snowflake and now
duct DB so here's an example of some of
these
um
I mentioning this because in some sense
Ibis is what we would have designed for
pandas it was actually designed by West
McKinney a few years later maintained by
by folkloud for quite a long time and
in some sense this could be pandas in
the future this is like one option and
I'll mention this in a few minutes
um
in the meantime there there's a
Consortium that's been going on for a
couple of years it's called Data apis
this is led by quantite uh and it's it's
a partnership across industry and the
idea here is both at the numpy API level
and at the data frame API level is to
establish a protocol so that you can
take one of these libraries and transmit
your data to another library in a very
easy way
um
and you may be wondering why does this
even exist and the answer is you know
everybody has you know everybody pretty
much is using the numpy API you know
like but they spell it slightly
differently you know tensorflow and Pi
torch and so I think this is this is a
great idea to really have a common
standard API uh at the array level
whether this is a good idea on the data
frame level is yet to be seen this is
you know everybody's essentially
adopting some version of the pandas API
which is as I said is not intentionally
designed so there's some issues
all right so let's talk about some of
the challenges that panda is facing
so you might have seen this blog post by
West McKinney this was in 2017. I don't
expect you to read this but in effect uh
pan is too far from the metal
um there's something you know it was
built it was very performant at the time
but the world has has changed a lot
since then
and so in 2018 actually in this room I
gave a talk on the future of pandas uh
looking back much what I said actually
would happen has happened we've achieved
some great Milestones like we have a
full API for extension arrays these
enable support for categorical missing
value support across data types these de
facto provide a clean mental model of
the block manager this is the the hated
internals of pandas instead you can use
extension arrays and in in effect get a
dick-like internal API
um we have a lot a lot more support
nowadays where we dispatch to various
operations to arrow for example this is
the backbone of the parquet and orc
readers and writers uh recently we
enabled um I think this is a 1.4 uh we
can now dispatch for
um the Aero CSV reader it's a
multi-threaded CSU reader and of course
I mentioned earlier this can now back
the uh string data type extension data
type in pi Arrow
uh recently in 1.5 we've also so we now
have actually all data types can be
backed by pi Arrow which is a super
powerful feature it's not by default but
you can you can create them
in addition to Arrow we can actually
also dispatch to number for various
operations over the years we built um
support uh both for the rolling methods
and the group I so that you can one of
the primary use cases of this is
actually to
make your user Define functions uh super
performing if they can be jitted by
number then you get really super
performance on this
um interesting enough we actually had
another goal in mind here which was to
really build out the same algorithms
that we have inside them but build them
in Python and then we use number to jit
them and actually they're quite
performant
um of course
the one problem here is we can't just
simply ditch all the psython code uh
number is not is still an optional
dependency as a zero actually and so but
if that ever changes then we would be
able to ditch a lot of the cycling code
so that would be uh interesting
um it's great for the I think
contributors really because then you can
actually edit
um just python code rather than having
to really dig into the Cyclone code
number also brings to it the possibility
of doing parallelism under the hood and
of course GPU integration
Mr Richards there we go but there's an
elephant in the room
um we couldn't address everything on
this list we've done a lot of things
there's been solid but incremental
progress the internals are still too far
from the metal there's a lack of
transparency into memory use and RAM
management and of course you know pandas
is sometimes slow it only it does not
necessarily have multi-core algorithms
certainly not inbuilt and we do dispatch
to some multi-core algorithms for some
things but not everything
so pandas has essentially we'll call it
the data tooling Spectrum
for small data really works super well
and even medium-sized data so what
medium-sized data has been growing in
size like if you're using pandas up to
10 gigabytes or something it works
beautiful
above that you can certainly use it and
a lot of people do but it does tend to
break down when you get a little bit
bigger than that
and so are there any easy solutions here
why can't we just use the giant machine
from AWS
or should I just use distributed
distributed data frames
and I mean there's a lot of trade-offs
here
um for example uh you have to balance
you know are things easy to use uh can I
use the same API uh how much does it
cost how much you know do I have to
migrate my code but I step back and I
say okay well first question is do you
really need this kind of scale and there
are some workloads that absolutely do
but I'll claim that something like 90
workloads don't need this type of scale
and so it's not really a big problem and
if it is you just get a bigger machine
this works a lot of the time
surprisingly well
um but there are times when it does
break down
and so that's why we're kind of at a
Crossroads here where does pandas where
does pandas go from here
and so I'm going to present three
Alternatives here of what we could think
about doing
um
so number one
this is you know what if we undertook
rewriting pandas with a modern back end
and what I mean by that is keep the API
and strip out the back end and you know
maybe just dispatch directly to Pyro
it's an option
um
this would make pandas you know grow
I suppose but I think we'd have to end
we'd end up breaking a lot of
compatibility this way the issue is that
a lot of choices that other packages
have made like we'd have to either try
to replicate at some cost to preserve
the exact semantics or we'd have to
break them
um we would in effect be getting into
the business of competing with everybody
else
might be a good thing
um and this would need a lot of
collaborations for this to happen we
would need substantial funding even
though we have a fair amount of funding
right now this would need substantial
funding we almost need a company to back
this
so another option is we'll call it that
way don't change just keep incrementally
improving
this maintains backwards compatibility
pandas is already pretty mature
um we have relatively you know
small number of bugs there's a lot of
bugs okay but there's a lot of surface
area too but I'll say there's a
relatively uh low incidence of you know
there's a lot of edge cases
um and this covers a lot of existing use
cases so this is why I think pandas um
this is really
I'll fast forward to the end this is a
good choice for pandas
um of course what ends up happening here
is we we may lose users this way there
may be people who simply cannot use it
in some some cases and and
as you get bigger that that can happen
um the nice thing about this this is
actually covered by the existing funding
this is how we've been proceeding for
the last few years
um
and you know over the last few years
we've added you know quite a bit of
features this is this is since um last
couple years here a lot of these
features here
um and interesting enough there's been
um these are extension rays that have
been added by external people and so I
think this is really a great way to
proceed where people can build upon some
of the apis that have been established
inside pandas
um we're actually in 2.0 which is not
super far away we're going to be turning
on
um
copy and write it'll still be
experimental this is you know a long
time ask feature there's a great talk by
uh one of the pandas core maintainers I
think it was that um Pi data Paris last
year or something like that by by yours
vanderbosch
so let me present another alternative
here this is I call it the other way
let's embrace the expressiveness of
pandas and in let's use pandas and scale
it in a way where we can both have the
ex we can have our cake and eat it too
so we want to take the pros of
of that way which is you know pandas is
compatible uh you can do a lot of things
with it at a very detailed level
um and people are very familiar with it
um now this does introduce two tools
and so you know I don't check that box
here because that's you could do that as
a negative
uh and you do have to switch your API
again
for folks in the open source world you
know it's hard to switch your API I
would offer it's almost impossible to
get people to really switch your API
wholesale if you're starting a new
project of course you can do it but
existing people are just not going to
migrate
um
one reason we're embracing this inside
two segment is we can actually do this
we can say okay you are going to use
this API
um and to the extent we're building a
whole ecosystem around this we can we
can make this work very effectively
so I'm going to show a little bit of our
what we call the bamboo Tech stack this
is an internal name for what our
basically our modeling workflow
and I will put on my hat now this is my
two Sigma hat
put in my head on
so we build upon a top of Ibis this is
the library I mentioned earlier that has
a a fairly well designed API but the key
is that
we're building on top of this so we're
taking Ibis as a one of our components
um we're not forking it we are simply
using it in place uh we're using a lot
of the apis of Ibis
and what this allows us to do is to
provide one of the backends we use is
pandasite side so this allows us to use
pandas because it's easy to debug it's
easy to test it works very well for
small data sets and it's very familiar
just works
when we need to scale what we can do is
we can take the same exact code and say
run it on spark or task this allows us
to get the distributed nature and we can
actually then handle much larger data
sets without changing our code at all
furthermore we can use we have an
internal engine which is a back end it's
a proprietary engine that we built that
can again take the same exact code and
run it in production
so here's an example of uh what we what
we might want to do this looks exactly
like uh you know Ibis code
um the interesting thing for us is not
necessarily uh you know yes we do joins
we add columns we do filtering but one
of our key aspects here is we support
what's called user-defined functions
this is the key aspect where you dump
your logic in a very
um specific way and that itself is
executed in pandas
um in this case it's actually executed
numpy but same idea
um so that's an example there
so
but is this enough
and the answer is for most use cases
this actually is we can handle small
data sets we can handle long history
data sets uh VR distributed back ends
but there's actually use case we want to
support we want to support really large
data so recently we've been contributing
uh in a to Ibis itself and another
related project called substrate which
basically allows us to dispatch to an
arrow back end it's called Acero and
this this back end allows us to do
streaming computations this is a joint
venture that we've been working on with
Voltron data
um this is interesting because now we've
gone sort of the other way
um where
we now again we have another backend we
can plug in without changing code and we
can handle different use cases so it's
sort of like write your code once and
then you can just pick how you want to
do it
all right so we're to Crossroads what do
we pick here
Well my two Sigma head is on and it
should be clear that we've picked option
three we've we've picked we've braced
the power of expressiveness and the
flexibility of using pandas and yet we
also have the ability to dispatch to uh
distribute it or streaming back ends as
we need and let me make one point clear
here is that we're using open source as
much as possible here there is no
forking going on
um we are just simply embracing the
components that are out there and then
using them writing small wrappers where
we need around it
let me take my head off and put my
pandas hat on
don't actually have a pen set but this
is my cute pandas picture okay so what
should pandas do and you know really
we're basically down to option one or
option two I don't think the world can
necessarily people can use Ibis I don't
necessarily think pen itself can use
Ibis that would be a major API change
um and so we're down to do we rewrite or
do we just continue as we are and I've
made it you know my thoughts have
probably come through before you know a
major rewrite I think if we could offer
a tremendous new functionality to folks
might be acceptable to the to the work
to the open source World
um I don't know if that's essentially
true and so I think um embracing option
two
which is pretty much uh slow not slow
but incremental progress uh through
pandas is the sort of the way to go here
um so in summary uh you know Panda
started quite a long time ago uh it's
grown up over the years gotten some
funding uh and today we are standing at
these Crossroads
so you know please help us build a
better future
these are some great packages to
contribute in open source there was a
talk Yesterday by Gail Forsyth an
engineer at Voltron data you can check
that out and there's a talk uh there's
talked yesterday by Matt Rocklin and
also a tutorial tomorrow on dasc please
contribute to these projects
um
and if you're interested in in full-time
employment two Sigma offers many
different categories of
jobs
please visit us at careers.2signal.com
and thanks
[Applause]
I think we have just a couple minutes or
questions right yeah okay um thank you
Jamie we have five minutes for questions
okay
between option one and option two one
way to put it is you pick option two
because there isn't enough that could be
delivered to take option one worth it
what kind of feature would change your
mind
so the question was uh the difference
between option one and option two is
what you know what if we what kind of
feature would make we us choose option
one essentially a rewrite of the Panda's
back end
um
it's a good question
um I mean I think there's a lot of
features that are actually shown in a
number of libraries like you know like
like in polars or Vex where you can
really do out-of-core computation on
these data sets
the question is is that really enough to
to really go down this path of a full a
full-on rewrite
it would be nice to do this I don't know
if that's enough
it's just it's a fair amount of effort
to get there that's the problem so
that's
so thank you very much for reviewing
visitation I'm thinking uh how much this
is a Crossroads actually like today
option one is probably not gonna happen
because there's no funding and also no
will to do that and option two enables
option three or it's kind of related
right because people will start either
switching to something else or
abstracting on top of pandas to then be
able to swapped it back in so yeah
the real question is how do you think
it's going to play out in the future
like what the substrate is going to be
for
so the question is how is this going to
play out in the future
um
you know I mean this is one of uh you
know so just to give you a little more
flavor uh you know Wes is the is the
founder of uh one of the founders of
Voltron data uh and you know this was
sort of the vision a few years ago of
you know the quote unquote you know
pandas 2.0 and
he essentially concluded that you needed
a complete rewrite and so what he
actually did is he's you know started
forming
um you know Arrow as a a fundamental
building block of libraries so we've
decoupled the the the the the stack here
so Now API is not simply tied to
implementation now we have an actual
implementation and you can pick your own
API now I don't think that's actually
particularly a great idea in the sense
that I mean decoupling is obviously a
great idea what I don't think is like
the world would be better off if we had
one API actually now the question is is
the world better off with the pandas API
the world currently has the pandas apis
at better off
I think we should evolve it I mean
that's really what I think we should do
um pandas is here will it be here in
five or ten years
in some form yes will it be the dominant
Library I don't know you know in my
experience you know replacing a fairly
complete and dominant a fairly complete
library that does most of what you want
is actually really hard because you
can't offer you know there's a question
earlier you can't offer such compelling
value that it's just dead easy to switch
you can only offer incremental value
when you have incremental value it's
very hard to sort of afford a complete
rewrite
when you put your two Sigma
that you've worked on there that sort of
graph paper Helm you know
various features are you aware of any
open source projects
um so the question is uh am I aware of
any open source uh projects that are
doing something like option three where
we we provide wrappers around
um uh the open source libraries um
not really
um I imagine you know just to give you a
flavor of like example inside what we
have to do is build uh you know Bridges
to our our data connectors you know we
obviously have storage systems and
things like that which we need to talk
to so those are the kind of wrappers or
things that you want to want to talk to
um and so again you want to build you
know once you have a modular system it's
very easy to plug in components at the
edges here
probably didn't answer your question but
anything else I think we're out of we
out of time yeah
but any more questions
um I guess we take one more and then if
you want to ask questions I'll be up
here
so when you're working with extremely
large data sets
how much data we want to handle for
laser values
okay so two questions uh first was uh
expand a little bit on the time series
aspects of pandas so I think pandas
became really super useful uh early on
because it you know it literally allowed
you to you know have ordered data do
things like order merges uh and it had
whole you know things like it actually
had date operations uh These Little
Things Early on actually I think
mattered a lot uh in some of uh for its
early adoption
um and the second question was
ah yes so pen is actually so the
question is um
how does lazy evaluation affect pandas
and the answer is it actually doesn't
pandas is eagerly evaluated and the
question is how does
um
so but all these other libraries
actually are lazy evaluated okay so
pandas itself is not now I mentioned
before uh the streaming back end that
we're building uh in open source this is
an interesting point because one of the
reasons you so one of the problems with
a distributed data frame library is that
you know as more and more data grows you
actually have to keep either having more
workers or more memory in aggregate you
have to hold everything in memory so
this is why we're actually in fact
moving toward a streaming back end
because that provides a guarantee of a
of a bounded chunk here where you can
only use a certain amount of memory at
one time so that's I think how you bound
It ultimately
a library which so this this is this is
the streaming back end we're building to
uh anacera which is a pyro engine here
it's extremely back end
if any other questions please
[Applause]